take a moment say your goodbyes chris
harrison is saying goodbye to the
bachelor franchise
after 19 years as host e.t has learned
that negotiations over chris's exit have
been
underway for a while but concluded late
monday night it's the final rose tonight
and a source tells e.t that the longtime
host will receive an eight-figure payout
as part of his exit agreement
in an instagram post on tuesday chris
expressed gratitude
following the major announcement writing
i've had a truly incredible run as host
of the bachelor franchise
and now i'm excited to start a new
chapter i'm so grateful to bachelor
nation for all of the memories we've
made together
while my two-decade journey is wrapping
up the friendships i've made will last a
lifetime
we're a victim of our own success being
around 15 years but i get to know and
love a lot of these people and they kind
of become friends and family and
and now they're married and having
babies and it's it's a beautiful thing
of course this all comes after he
announced in february that he would be
taking a step back from the franchise
after his controversial comments during
an interview with rachel lindsay
where he appeared to defend bachelor
contestant rachel kirknell's past
racist actions the picture was reported
from 2018
at an old south antebellum party so i
think
you know when you when you it's
when you hold down a good book no
it's not a good well rachel is it a good
look in 2018 or is it not a good look in
2021
because there's a big difference after
facing backlash for his controversial
remarks
chris issued an apology and during a
virtual appearance on good morning
america in march
he admitted he quote made a mistake i am
an imperfect man
i made a mistake and i own that
i believe that mistake doesn't reflect
who i
am or what i stand for
i am committed to the progress not just
for myself
also for the franchise the 49 year old
reality host
also expressed his hope to someday
return to the franchise
i plan to be back and i want to be back
this interview
is not the finish line there is much
more work to be done
and i am excited to be a part of that
change chris started hosting the abc
series in 2002 and later went on to host
its spin-offs like the bachelorette
bachelor in paradise and more and i
think for me as the host producer friend
psychologist that i am
it allowed me in deeper and allowed me
to do my job better and be a better
friend be a better confidant
but bachelor nation hasn't seen the
reality host do his job in a while now
in march former nfl star emmanuel acho
stepped in to host the bachelors after
the final rose special from matt
james it's time to look ahead to the
future shortly after
abc announced that former bachelorettes
caitlyn bristow and tasha adams with
co-host katie thurston's journey to find
love
let the journey begin bring on the mess
do you think it was important for him to
take some time away step away
and like you know give it some room yeah
i mean i echo everything that the alumni
have come together
to speak on chris and you know i think
he's taking the time away which is
probably a good decision for him do you
think he should come back at all
you know i think whenever he feels like
he's ready then that's a decision that
he has to make you know with the the
franchise
as for michelle young's upcoming season
of the bachelorette
e.t has learned that there are no
decisions yet on who will host
i'm just excited i'm ready to get
started but in the meantime producers
are focused on bachelor in paradise as
it's set to begin filming
in late june et has learned that there
will be multiple celebrity guest hosts
filling in during the upcoming season
david spade being one of them i am the
ultimate
i mean that's what i do i help people
find love as for bachelor nation a
source tells e.t that chris is exited
could be good and positive quote they
are excited about this new chapter for
the show
and are thinking of it as a new
opportunity for more people to become
fans and part of the bachelor family
former bachelor colton underwood shared
a heartfelt message to the longtime host
on instagram
so did former leads jojo fletcher ari
liondyk jr
and sean lowe who expressed their love
and well wishes
you